hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to slay away camp they
thought summer camp would be fun nanos
it wasn't long before they realized in
see deadly
Slayer we care
yes the game where you were the murderer
and you have to I don't know annihilate
these poor people that are just trying
to have a fun time at camp you
anticipate back at Ditka tree but before
I even get started in the game I wanted
to mention something about the game
options menu and you may be thinking to
yourself like well mark we know you're
scraping the bottom of the barrel of
creativity here but you're really just
gonna show us the game menu hang on hold
off on those on those messages of hate
your timing up right now I just I
thought this was funny cuz I was playing
around with the options like I always do
and then there's a sliders button and
the more you do the sliders more options
there are and I don't know I I found it
funny they had in blooding increased the
level of blood splash ah city and bone
ism adjust level of bone chunk madness I
don't even know what this is field of
view
my god that the [ __ ] dis happened to him
yeh feel ya na full field yes volumetric
doc I don't know call upon the bark of
the wild for maximum immersion okay oh
Jesus
oh jeez what have I done Shamala metric
frog just the fraction of space-time in
which frogs exist in an alternate
dimension okay quad reception adjust the
levels in which quadrant ions quadricep
through the inner most velocities okay
dark suspicions you don't take a look at
this slider alright okay ear gut phys
enhance increases gel model jiggle
dynamics oh oh Jesus is about to say
hopefully that applies to boobs but
there's boobs right here as well it just
increases your anime collections sake
animes gel physics uses real time flab
rendering groups okay
hidden space and beginning increase if
your hidden surfaces are too micro
little no no that means eradicate your
current progress in beginning a new is a
fresh soul a psycho-killer born from the
darkness
started I have no idea how to play I
don't know how to play oh jeez Oh God
I'm sorry children that is a lot of
imploding and that is a lot of an Bonin
ting oh geez
just the way slaps into the whoops
that's a murderer for you all right
slide and kill the camp Safety Officer
okay good thing there are footprints to
know exactly where I need to go oh oh
geez
that's a little horrifying I guess
that's the point
goodbye all righty then so yeah this is
what the game is about it's like a it's
like a delightful puzzle murder game ah
which is you know the best slaughter the
teenagers what could be better in a game
and that goddamn dog he's to stop
barking all the place okay so if i if i
spoop one of these is it gonna spook all
over and yeah uh-oh oh [ __ ] that's
really horrifying oh man sorry
oh she's honestly on I don't know I feel
about this
at least the bunnies are okay the
adorable little bunnies over there
they're gonna be just fine they're not
gonna get in blood and bonus kill click
when the skulls in the red zone in the
kill zone Oh God
well I hit I got bonus kill coins
why is this supposed to be an app see
how they run
no no if I want to see how they run Wow
oh geez ahead put it into oblivion oh
boy
Oh boobs Kiki jeez that's such a
horrible person but I guess I'm a
murderer so what does it matter
oh jeez alrighty then well I'm doing
wonderfully hope you all are having a
good day
murder scares other people yeah I would
imagine that em yeah whoa oh no so
scared are you
well too bad you're about to be uh-oh
okay I know it yeah yeah ha oh god oh no
what are you gonna do to me what are you
do oh you got a murder me ah
and now he's dead and he got exploded is
that like supposed to be the the Jason
vortex
oh my god the amount of blood maybe two
in blood and sequential slice oh all
right hey Becky busca oh geez oh geez
wait how am I gonna get out of here oh
oh oh oh oh so what I need to do is I
need to not kill that guy first
we got a conundrum here yeah I'm gonna
turn off that dog bark
goddamnit the bolometric dog was just
too much okay
ooh that's handy
ah okay I got it okay flooby-doo ski
kill zone Oh be sure sorry
apparently that murder was amazing el
fuego de la muerte the fire of the death
the death fire the fire fire the death
we got to be tactical about this because
I want to murder correctly does this
mean that I can't
how about ski
Oh God
you're fighting on that stepping into a
campfire would do that holy [ __ ] I'm
never going camping again Ernie then
reminder these can Oh what happens if I
go okay Lebowski sorry sorry about that
sorry guys I'm terribly so what did I
punch his head off I just
what is that clean oil Tiki trickery
okay I don't know what that means
boo I guess you're not scared huh hello
Babu oh but I can't go there I'll die ah
I see yeah hello ah that's how you do it
I got it okay I like this by the way
besides all the murder I ripped his
heart out Merrick is art out but I mean
between the murder kill coundown
finishing six turns are out the police
are gonna come get me well alrighty then
but I mean it's it's the mixture of
murder with like the cutesy art style
that really makes it for me
how about ski all right yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] oh now they got me you
know wait what am I an idiot what am i
stupid with that why am I so dumb
yeah oh you wanna what I can only assume
is a pumpkin based on the sign behind
you oh if I'd have known pumpkins were
that dangerous that every would have
smashed them final scene a whole a whole
one a whole load of murder what happens
if I go in the hole hello okay well I'm
only six feet under it doesn't I mean
that's too bad
hello jeezum holy balls first movie
complete yay we got a movie done oh my
god welcome to the video store click on
the shop buttons and I'll show you
something
ok shrub this is the shop here's a
thousand coins click AG or pack random
special kill to unlock it oh oh I could
gets pronged broken-hearted after the
bonus double behind face people
charbroiled demonize juice not not the
bees I want not the bees oh god I want
not the bees Oh
bees one bumble bee is kind of cute a
whole bunch are still kind of cute but
they also might kill you pray here
you're unlocked Gor pax go to the killer
shelf for some fun unlock killers by
playing movies we use the mystery box
for a surprise once you've saved up
enough skull coins now return to the
movie shelf okay a new movie came in
click on it to start slaying oh geez
return to slay away camp they thought it
was safe to go back to camp but they're
stupid and it wasn't why would they go
back
safe to go back to camp but it wasn't
yeah it wasn't say we can't too
your turn to slay away camp Oh
maskull's coalface Yogi's really girls
oh god I love this game this game is
amazing I love everything about this
game scene one a really dumb cop oh my
goodness gracious oh my god okay um I
actually want to do more of this I want
to do more episodes of this this is a
really cool game it's something like on
the surface it looks so simplistic but
the humor of it and like the silliness
of it and like the greenness of it
juxtaposed by the cuteness of it is this
really interesting to me and I love it a
lot like it's really fun even though
it's like a simple puzzle that's been
done before it's done in such a charming
way also will this kill me Bryce come
back where the sheepses does it guess I
was ugly doesn't mean that he had to
kill me for it oh well oh well right
then there we go Santa played by Rachel
abudance oh jeez oh that's awesome I
love that that's so good
oh it's all like movie based oh it's all
like movie oh it's so cool alright
anyway so that's all I meant to do for
this one but I am gonna new another
episode of this very soon
so let me know what you think of this
game down the comments below and thank
you everybody for watching and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]